et avec nous pour parler de cet attentat
nous sommes avec samia maktouf elle est
avocate de plusieurs familles de
victimes du terrorisme filets jaunes
bonjour samia maktouf merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'un nouveau cap a été
franchi hier
oui tout à fait et coupé c c'est là
qu'on certaine consternation c'est c'est
la colère c'est l'effroi comme vous
l'avez dit c'est un nouvel attentat
contre nos institutions
alors que le procès de charlie hebdo et
est en cours alors qu'on a on à tenter
de bâillonner nos journalistes
on a tué des journalistes des policiers
des concitoyens de confession juive et
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de deux de
l'école de la république c'est cesser
c'est consternant c'est c'est une fois
de plus la preuve que ce procès est plus
que nécessaire il est utile et vous
savez c'est depuis l'ouverture de ce
procès que des menaces ont été formulées
de manière précise et claire contre ce
procès parce que cette tranche de deux
personnes qui sont dans la barbarie dans
l'idéologie mortifère refuse ont su ce
que les valeurs de la république passe
écoutait ccc une fois de plus
consternant d'autant que aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de ce procès il ya des
familles qui qu'ils sentent qu'ils sont
plaqués qui assistent et qui est dans
l'est dans la douleur sont à vif dans
les blessures ne sont pas encore
cicatrisées
bien sûr j'ai une pensée émue aux
familles de cet enseignant qui qui qui
est là pour enseigner les valeurs de la
république pour apprendre et ou en
dehors de l'école doit-on à prendre ce
jeu
le dialogue le former un lampion à
apprendre le contradictoire et apprendre
à dialoguer à apprendre à critiquer donc
oui c'est vraiment consternant oui samia
maktouf c'est cette fois l'éducation qui
a été touchée qu'est ce que cet attentat
visant donc un professeur va entraîner
ce qu'on va devoir mettre les
établissements sous surveillance
policière
écoutez c'est des décisions qui devront
être prises par le ministère de de
l'éducation mais en tout cas ce que je
pense c'est que nos écoles les épaules
de la république au sein d'une
démocratie au sein de la république sont
se sont protégés donc je ne sais pas
quelles mesures seront prises mais en
tout cas pour moi les mesures les plus
urgentes et les plus les plus nécessaire
aujourd'hui c'est c'est un élan de
d'éveil un élan de peut-être de de prise
de conscience encore plus que plus
qu'avant sur cette barbarie qui tentent
de s'incarner de de s'exprimer au sein
de nos institutions
on a parlé d'une nouvelle loi sur le
séparatisme
mais cette loi vous savez il faut pas
s'attendre à ce qu'elles donnent des
fruits immédiatement
aujourd'hui les mesures les plus
efficaces me semble-t-il sont celles qui
seront prises dans le premier noyer
noyau de la société à savoir la famille
et puis et puis
d'ailleurs c'est l'occasion pour saluer
vous donner l'occasion de saluer nos
efforts et l'efficacité de nos forces de
police
mais aujourd'hui je pense qu' il ne faut
pas que chaque enseignant se sentent
autocensure et vous savez il ya tout a
bougé en vue justement ça vient maktouf
excusez-moi de vous couper le professeur
victimes de cet attentat aurait permis à
des élèves musulmans de sortir de la
classe pour ne pas qu'il soit blessé
pendant ce court où il l'aurait montrer
ses caricatures on en est là justement à
mme bhutto censure des professeurs
justement c'est pour ça vous avez vos il
faut rappeler que dans le l'école de la
république et dans certaines écoles de
la république il y à des tabous il ya
des ddd sujet qu'on ne peut pas que les
enseignants ne peuvent pas abordés tels
que l'enseignement de la religion
il ya des sujets tels que la shoah ou
par exemple l'éducation l'enseignement
biologique et autres voire même dans
certains lycées
yanni fils ne peuvent pas sous prétexte
de d'avoir des des complications contre
tel ou tel produit refuse d'aller et de
pratiquer le sport est précisément là la
piscine vous savez c'est cette cesser
toute censure qui il ne faut pas il faut
pas que cette autocensure s'installe au
sein de la société et pour se plier de
l'exemple vous venez de dire dans cette
dans ce lycée est ce ce processeur moi
ce qui me choque c'est que un
enseignement puisse être disposé à des
élèves de la république et pas à
d'autres
c'est ça la le séparatisme c'est ça le
communautarisme c'est ça le leu leu
donné raison à certaines personnes et au
sein d'une république ce n'est pas
possible c'est les valeurs de la
république qui doivent d'être qui
doivent tronet haut de la hiérarchie des
normes
vous savez aujourd'hui les normes cesser
ces normes de la république et non des
normes d'origine religieuse aux autres
qui doivent prévaloir et cela c'est un
travail qui doit être fait en profondeur
et sur du long terme
c'est sur du long terme qui doit être
fait lorsqu'on voit ce qui se passe dans
les prisons ou les prisons de deux jours
en jours on se rend compte en se versant
soit votée et que c'est là comme l'
incubateur du terrorisme
il faut agir merci beaucoup
samia maktouf je rappelle que vous êtes
avocate de plusieurs familles de
victimes du terrorisme